This is Jocko podcasts number 117 with echo Charles and me Jacque a willing
Good evening echo good evening, and we're doing a Q&A
tonight first one in a while
had a bunch of other guests and books and whatnot so cue a
Let's go
cool first question
Jocko from 1/15 podcast number 115 as a leader
How best to respond to someone like corporal Meyer when he brings up good questions in in a brief that need to be addressed without
derailing the brief and calling your
competence slash authority into question
Okay, so what he's talking about is on podcast 115 with Dakota Meyer, which if you haven't listened to it and listen to it
It's long, and it's very I don't know it's it's awesome. Anyways in part of that podcast
Dakota is getting told
How they're gonna conduct this operation and Dakota?
raises some point and says what about this what about that and what about this other thing and
They don't listen to him and so the question here is if you're in charge
You're the leader and you get someone that brings up these questions during a brief
During a plan that you need to be that need to be addressed. How do you do it? How do you handle that properly?
Okay, well first of all and the most important part of this is if you involve your team in the planning itself
You won't have these questions come up during the brief. They'll come up during the planning mm-hmm
So that's that's the ultimate and best way to solve this problem
you don't plan in a vacuum as the leader and then present the plan to the troops and
Expect that you're gonna have the perfect plan you didn't use only your brain working on it. What about everyone else's brain?
What about everyone else's perspective they have experience, and they have knowledge that you don't have so
If you involve them in the planning then they ask you those questions early and you figure out what the right?
Answers to those questions are so that's how you solve the problem right there
Now if it happens that for whatever reason you're you
didn't have the opportunity to do that or you didn't do it well enough or whatever the case may be and
Now you start getting questions on your while you're briefing
Well first of all if they ask you questions that you don't have answers to
Then that that could indicate that you're wrong, actually you could actually be wrong and not a lot of leaders like
to feel that way
But you should actually be
Happy that someone on your team is pointing out something that is gonna make the plan better as a whole hmm, so
There's that
And and it's really easy if someone if you're in a brief and someone
Brings up a point that you didn't think of and it makes sense well, then you can implement that into the plan
Okay, so that now you might think that
It hurts your authority
Right to say hey, that's a good point Aiko. I didn't think of that
Let's implement you might think or feel like that's gonna
Make you look bad
But the opposite is actually true if I go no echo
Hey, the plans already completed you weren't there for the planning, so just be quiet. That's the guy that no one respects
That's the guy that's not looking good as a leader
That's the person that's losing authority, so you don't look weak if you listen to members of the team whether they're junior or senior
It also shows that you're incompetent
if
You because because you missed a party obviously the question is pertinent that they asked or I should say if the question is pertinent
And it is a good point then it shows that you miss an important angle of the plan
so
Open your mind open your put your ego in check and incorporate it in there
now
This can also happen if there's something that you know that
you're right on but it's something that you know that you're right on if there's something like that and
You end this bleep. Maybe you get one particular individual that keeps pushing back and keeps pushing back and
You might have to in those cases say you know what hey echo
Let me let me talk to you after this brief is over and I'll explain to you exactly while we're doing it this way
Mm-hmm so that way doesn't derail the brief because it might take a longer explanation than you want to you know for instance the typical
SEAL briefing was we try to keep it 50 minutes to an hour so if you've got if you got to spend eight minutes
pulling up a different map and explaining some detail of the terrain to this guy that has a
Protest to what you're saying you might say hey listen when we get done with this brief. I'll pull your side
Let me show you the let me show you the terrain map and you can see exactly while we're using this insertion route or whatever
the case may be
so you
Can do that if you have to and?
Even then they might end up having a point that you didn't see and then you can say, okay well
I didn't see that and now we have to give everyone a quick
rebreathing on some change in the plan
But again none of this will happen if you bring your subordinates in and you let them
Do first of all let them do the planning that's ideal let them come up with Lana
Let echo come up with the plan. I'm not coming up the plan you go come up the plan
I'm gonna check with you and make sure that the plan is going in the right direction make sure it's not totally off track
and then
You'll incorporate all these things
And I'll have a better view of the plan I can stand back and be the tactical genius as we talk about the book extreme
Ownership like that's how you do it hmm, so
That's the answer
well at least is an
Answer, yeah, maybe other people have other answers
Seems to make sense to me yeah, that's that hard. It's hard right when you when you
it's one of those things you always got to be conscious of when you have a plan or whatever and
someone
For lack of a better term pokes holes in it mm-hmm like hey, what about this?
What about this and then?
you have that those two elements that you got to keep in mind where it's like the fact that it's your plan and then the
Plan you know the effectiveness. I mean your emotional attachment to the plan
Yeah, you got to keep the emotional attachment to the plan in check versus the actual
Effectiveness of the plan yeah and people have a hard time doing that and what's cool
What's cool is once you break away from that mindset?
Then it's really easier just to be and and everyone just kind of knows. Oh, yeah, chuckles. You know he's got an open mind
He'll listen to you. Yeah as opposed to someone that has a closed mind every goes
I'll you can't you can't give me anything by this guy and he's gonna keep
He doesn't even help to point things out because he won't listen and then guess what you're using one brain versus
20 brains you know and more important than the brainpower the perspective the
Different perspectives is the guys in the ground of the guys with the technical knowledge and the tactical knowledge?
They're gonna know things that you don't know that's the way it is mmm
You can't know everything that they know mm-hmm
And so if you shut down all those different perspectives you're looking at something from one angle
You know do you see the whole complete picture when you only look at something from one angle? No you don't know sir
Use those other perspectives you know
check
Self-correcting machine mmm. Yes getting let go of the ego the
Taking to personal well personally when I was in the SEAL Teams
I called it the emotional attachment to the plan yeah
Because I see these people come up with plans and they would be so addicted to their own plan only because it was their own
Plan not for any not for any tactical or strategic or operational reason whatsoever just like because they thought of it, yeah
That's natural. Yeah. It's very natural yeah, and there's some element of of
Benefit to that right because if you're passionate about your plan
And I'm passion about my plan as long as we can eventually come to compromise
Then we've put forth the best idea because I don't want you to not be passionate about your plan while you're planning it
I wasn't really coming up with the best plan that you really believed it and and it's interesting
you know you talk about poking holes right poking holes in the plan and
We all know that it's very easy to sit back and poke holes
Oh, man, and what I'm telling you to do as a leader is to
Absolutely do that not be a jerk no no
And I'm talking as a leader if I if I let you do the planning then it's easy for me to sit back and poke
Holes in the plan right which is good. It's good because we're gonna come up with we're gonna fill those holes once
I poke the holes we're gonna fill them. We're gonna know that they're taken care of also as a leader from a
From a perspective point you think aim chocolate really knows what's going on
He was able to find these holes in the plan the real reason I was able to find him is just because I was not
totally
at
Miniscule detail when you were I was up at altitude
Relaxing looking around yeah, it's gonna. I don't want to say cheating such cheating, but it is cheating is
Cheating it's that much easier. It's so much easier to sit back and do it yeah
And let things go that way like when you know when you watch a movie, and you have like some critique the movies
Outstanding, and then you have some critique ahead
I shouldn't have chose that guy for that role or whatever you mean while the movie is like
Groundbreaking whatever you know so it's easy to poke holes the movie meanwhile like yeah, yeah when it's done
You're all like poking holes up the little imperfections
Do that all the time make sense I dig it does it happen with your videos
Probably Jack anyway next question
We have been training jiu-jitsu for two months now
We started actually rolling a few weeks ago from our knees on the mat like not starting from standing basically
I've trained for an
executed multi oh
I've trained for and executed multiple marathons competed
completed a number of tough mudders trained hard in CrossFit hiked biked swam and nothing compares to the total mental and physical exhaustion I
feel after training jiu-jitsu
How can I combat this?
time
Train more supplements just suck it up
When I get home, I'm so beat in the next morning. I wake up feeling like I was hit by a bus
Despite the exhaustion and still sucking at it. It's super fun
Okay, so that's the jujitsu that's the and okay, so there's a couple things here
Yes, it's gonna take some time you're gonna have to train you train more your body will become conditioned to it
That's probably number one number two is
And this is so hard for people to do relax
It's really hard. It's really hard for people to do especially when you first start out I
realized that
The way you get to a point when you start to relax
is
when you're when when the
capability of your technique
Surpasses the capability of your strength mm-hmm, so if I know that I can escape
your
choke attempt
By holding your hand and pulling your thumb and pulling your arm off, and that's what I know
that's what I'm gonna do when I realize that I can use a technical escape of
Swimming my arm in and then placing my hips on the ground and then scooting away
from your choke
I'll do that instead but but until we figure out the techniques all we have is
muscle so you the way you do is you you just have to keep keep training and keep training and
Sure, you can try can people actually when they try and relax
Do they actually get you you tell me so I always tell people like relax more like some will say I just can't relax
I'll be like relax harder
Yeah, but
But it's hot it's so hard for people to relax because people say oh, and I relaxed I just get submitted
Yeah, right, yeah, so but if you relax you'll at least be aware of what's happening
And if you relax you can think about the technical
the technical
Movement that you're supposed to do to escape mm-hmm
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I feel like just like how you said though if you don't know
The move you're just gonna go with what you know and it's gonna be the spaz in one way or another
You know if you if a guy's on you MS like that's never effective
Well cuz I cuz I'll all go and say yes, yes sometimes
I have to spaz and it Dean calls me out on that alone well
here's the thing good defense you just spazzing well, but yours has a
bigs more than a sprinkle of technique
You know that's the thing if true like you and I told you this one time
You know how like if you say yeah, you're strong and that's kind of an insult in jujitsu because it's like says yeah
You're strong, but you don't have technique
It's kind of like that's what you're implying, but and I said this to you one time
I was like you have like strength you're strong and you were like
Not defensive, but you're like no I have technique or whatever and I was like yeah
I know that I was like shoot. That sounded bad I
Mean you have technique. We already know that you've been training for 25 million years, and you have good technique
But with that technique is like a lot of strength in there like when you um
There's like stuff. Oh, yeah, when like if you if I'll be inside control on on top on you
And you have this like first so if your hands are in the correct spot just to begin with yeah
That's to be and you can just kind of
Get your leg in real easy every single time like I can't talk stuck it stop it, and I'm not weak
I'm not weak, but it's like the strength of that move. Yeah is like it's unstoppable, and that's when I said it
I was like you you're like strong when you do a technique
It's like it's a strong thing yeah, and I would say though. There's a lot of ooh
I would say it's probably 70% technique in 30% strength
Which which may confirm what you're saying you've got 30% strength
Yeah, is still more than if someone has 70% technique yet, they have only 10% strength to get back at all
Yeah, yeah, fully in even saying. It's you know 70 percent technique 30% strength
I mean, that's gonna vary from time from moment to moment or experienced extreme
so if you're spazzing
even that's gonna be a
Spectrum like how much strength?
Did you use this technique kind of things you can't suppose for a long time no your videos be tired. Yes, be gassed
Yeah, yeah so when I say you're strong
Here's the thing the fact is you're strong regardless of your technique or not you can lift a lot of weights
You're big try grab like I I'll grab your wrist and when you break the grip of the wrist
It's way more violent than the typical person you're a strong person, so there's no denying that I know it sounds like an insult
Whatever, but nonetheless back to the point
Yeah
if so if you if you have strength going in
Before you gain all that technique over the over the years
Just like how you said, that's what you're gonna use so the key is here, I think
is
to
Consciously and it's not easy consciously focus on the technique consciously like remember
Okay, where am I I'm in half guard right now because you know like in the beginning when you first learn the the positions
You're like half guard is real clear guard is real clear when you start rolling around. You're halfway upside down
Maybe you're twisting maybe your arms in the wrong spot across your body or something. You kind of don't remember. Oh wait
I'm in half guard right now or I'm upside down, but I'm in you know
I'm on his back still whatever so you don't he doesn't just stick in your mind
What position you're in but if you can do that then it starts to get in getting routine
So now you after that you can figure out, okay?
Am I safe here?
Because that's why you spaz that's why you you can't relax because you don't know if you're safe or not
So you're just trying to move in and get out of there
Or you know get a submission hurry up before he does something. You know where this applies to life this applies to life in
when you're interacting with other people and
you start to let's say you and I are having a disagreement about something sure right and
you start getting the upper hand on me hmm and
Instead of me trying to use a technique to get out all I do is go that stupid echo you're done, right
I just start interrupting you're cutting off raising my voice. I'm actually losing now, and I don't you know that but I'm relying on
Brute force yeah as opposed to technique now. It could be also like we talked about earlier could be that I'm wrong
And if instead of admitting that I'm wrong or or taking like you're saying relax and looking at the technique and saying you know what?
Echo has a point here that I can't debate against he's right
And I'm wrong I need to admit that same thing if you came up with an idea for the plan and your idea was better
Than mine or you had a point that I needed to
Bring into the plan unless like unless I can relax and actually pay attention
Then I'm not gonna be able to do that so that's how
That's one of the many ways when I always talk about jujitsu applying to life
This is another example of where hey if the argument starts to escalate and you're using brute force to get out of it
You're not winning. Just like you're not winning in jujitsu
It's it you're gonna gas out. You're gonna. You're gonna lose. Yeah, don't use brute force
Yeah
Yeah, not even 30% well. Maybe sometimes
The other thing is the other thing that's hard, and it's well. It's it's attached to what you're saying
Don't have death matches every time. Yeah, all right. Don't it like you find a partner and just be like okay
Let's try and make sure that we're not using so much strength I can roll with you or with Dean or with Andy
or whoever
For a long time and and it's a you know we're sweating we're tired
But we're not using all this strength don't walking off the mat with a with with thick burned-out muscles
Yeah, it's a difference more of a cardio
I would say then then a strength thing when you get to a higher level because you're you just movement its movement
That's happening. You know when do you know when someone's gonna?
Accomplish something and if you're gonna fight it with muscle you're gonna. You're gonna end up losing yeah, and
It goes back to the time thing where the house Essen is it more time and answers
yeah, it's more time because like you you learn that and again like where you
Knowing where to be and where not to be where you're safe and where you're not safe in jiu-jitsu is a big deal
So you know how like okay?
Let's say it's a and I know this with you because let's say if I pass your card
I'm sorry you let me pass your card. I don't know
you don't
Spaz and like you know like in a tournament where the guys like really trying hard to let you settle in guard and so
That's a different scenario of course
But um you never do that you it's like you get to a point past your guard once
You kind of get there you just you settling you're you're kind of relaxing
Because you it seems like anyway that you know you're not in danger for a submission
So that's kind of really where the focus is. It's not the fact that he passes my card. Oh, no, that's terrible
It's not that it's okay now what technique do I need to implement to keep myself safe
And the more you know about jujitsu the more you realize it doesn't take a huge amount of energy to implement that technique
It's usually just like an arm position or make sure his hip is like over there and not over here, and that's kinda
That's it that's pretty much it, but if you don't know that you're like oh, man
you're using your whole body to get out of there kind of thing and
That's that's when you're leaving no reserves in a military perspective
In the military you're always supposed to keep your reserves as long as you can oh, yeah
You're just you've ended a lot of serves trying to spaz out get out of a dominant position
You're also attacking a dominant position when you're spazzing to try and get out yeah
You're you're just going crazy trying to get out of this confirmed position
I mean across the side or the mount those are positions that are really
Sure, there's a transitional time when you should definitely spaz to try and get out once. That's surpassed
Well now you're just you're just expending energy. Yeah
So defense ladies check your diet, too
If you're like really sore and everything make sure you're getting enough protein make sure to get enough fat make sure you're getting
Maybe get some get some super krill or some or some joint warfarin or both
because
The your body needs it so just other things to try and put off that
Soreness and the pain, yeah, all right. Yeah all that twisting yeah, there's definitely you know well. Yeah, it's hard on your joints. Yeah
Work out you know they get a workout that you won't beginning doing other stuff
Yeah, unless yeah, you know construction or something like that same thing you're gonna get joint stuff
That's how but yeah, keep it supposed to be fun the death matches though death matches
Yeah, white belt death matches yeah, probably
I
Would estimate forty percent of all injuries in jiu-jitsu come from white belt death matches is that you think that's a good number?
Yeah, if not hot iron yeah
full-on yeah, yeah
Next question you
Talk about you talk about empathy and perspective and building relationships as a leader
But I look at leader a leader like Steve Jobs who's known for his hostile attitude toward people isn't that being?
Default aggressive like you talk about if I'm more
Naturally that type of leader should I go with it if it worked for Steve Jobs shouldn't it work for me
So
that's a good question and I
Haven't actually read the book about Steve Jobs, and I think there's probably more than one
But there's the one that's real popular real thick and someone gave it to me, and I have it and I will someday
but I haven't read it yet, and I've heard it's really good and all that and I that being said I've I've
heard the same things about
You know Steve Jobs the leadership style and he was real tyrannical, and I pulled a couple things here
Just from well here. We go in his book about jobs
Time at next and returned to Apple the second coming of Steve Jobs
Alan Deutsch 'men described jobs rough treatment of his underlings
He would praised as a quote he would praise and inspire them often in very creative ways
But he would also resort to intimidating goading berating belittling
And even humiliating them
so and there's another article
by Ronald
Regio, who's a PhD in psychology and the article came from Psychology Today, and it says he was obsessively
controlling and
Given to fits of rage throwing tantrums and yelling at employees and board members
He could tear down someone's ideas or the person himself in a public display
Some have said he took credit for others ideas and his confidence led to a sort of over-the-top arrogance
So the guys kind of tyrannical one time when they were putting together the MobileMe
Application, and it wasn't working well and jobs told the team that was putting it together you when it wasn't working you've tarnished Apple's reputation
You should hate each other for having let each other down
So
Okay, so first of all let's look at the fact that you've heard me say this before that people's strengths are their weaknesses and their
Weaknesses can be their strengths so in Steve Jobs case obviously
some of this stuff
Some of his weaknesses that we're talking about here were also strengths because he was totally beyond driven right he was
Completely obsessed with with doing good and all that and and he pressed
toward his vision extremely hard he was relentless in trying to make things happen and
again
those are very positive characteristics if you got someone that's really driven and they're driven to the point of almost being obsessed and
You you take that and those are kind of good characteristics, but when they go too far?
This is why it's dichotomy
This is a balance of leadership right when you go too far you become a tyrannical leader, which is not good
It's not good for a team, and it's and it's and a team that is subjected to that kind of attitude
will not perform as well as a unified team period
period
so
the guy was clearly hostile and
At the same time clear clearly he was one of the most successful business leaders in history right so
Would you look at him and say okay
Well, maybe I should be that way maybe I should be a tyrannical leader, and I would say to that no
You do not get to do that and here's why let's look at some other characteristics that Steve Jobs had
First of all he was perhaps the foremost
technological visionary in the history of the world
Right I mean. He had a vision of
Technology that very few people in the history in the world of had and I will go a little bit more narrow
I think he understood things on a note another level when it came to technology that the part of how?
human beings would interact with technology
That's the part that I think he really had just incredible vision for he realized like oh
These people won't want a computer in their house
And they'll want it to reflect the way they live and they're gonna want music in their pocket
They're gonna want all of the music in their pocket, and they're gonna want a phone that can do it
You know he had this vision of how people would interact with technology that I don't think too many people have hmm
So so that's number one number two he had a phenomenal
feel for design
right for design and how to merge form and function together in
In an in an
Aesthetically pleasing in an oftentimes stunning way if you look at the design
And that's uncommon especially for someone to have that feel for design and still have a massively
Technical background right so so that again. We're making a person
That's like 1% of 1% of 1% already on top of that
He got into business his business at the right time in the right place. He had the right background
on top of that
The guy could speak well the guy was very
articulate right he was very articulate with his vision if you do you watch his keynote speeches that he would give at the
Whatever it is when they have the Apple Convention. What's that thing called the?
Apple come in yeah, they have that thing well he'd get up on stage, and he'd talk about something and he would articulate that
And he would do it with real clarity
And he was very convincing and he was very captivating and people were you know they'd say apples a cult mmm
They'd follow that guy so he had
all those
Skills those world-class skills, and I'm not using that term lightly I'm talking world-class skills
and then they're all those class skills are combined together into one package one human being and
There you got you got Steve Jobs, so he's got all those advantages and then on top of that
he's had some luck along the way right he had some luck in his timing and his upbringing and in the
exposures that he got and being exposed to computer programming and those things back in the day was rare and he
Got lucky and having that unfold from so he had all these
things going for him
That helped propel him and his company to the top
So now if you're thinking maybe you should use his leadership style
the the questions that you should ask yourself is are you a
one-in-a-billion
the technological visionary or visionary of any kind
The answer that is likely no, and if you think it's yes, maybe you should check your ego a little bit
Then you have to ask yourself. Do you have an eye for design?
an
artistic eye for design like like da Vinci or Michelangelo
If you have that you probably don't if you think you have that maybe you should check your ego again
Are you a gifted speaker and storyteller?
And can you convey your vision with total clarity two big giant groups broad groups of people?
And if you think you can do that again you should check your ego
Can you count on luck or do you want to count on luck?
to close the gaps in some of those other areas so
If you could do all those things if you answered yes a hundred percent to all those questions, and okay, maybe you can get away
With being a kind of leader that Steve Jobs was
but if you're a normal person if you're a normal human being
then maybe you should try and be a good leader and
Maybe you should be a leader that builds relationships and forms cohesive teams and coalition's that
Help you drive your mission forward despite the ups and downs of whatever
Business you're in
so
That's it Steve Jobs had a lot of other things that made him successful
yeah, and
Leadership, and he I've got to eventually read the book, but he clearly had some people around him that
that
utilized
That skill the skills that he did had and have and moved and helped move him forward right other people at the company other people
Early and in Apple we saw that hey
You know what this guy?
He might be a little bit hard to deal with but he's got some things that we won't find anywhere else
So let's prop them up and let's move forward. Yeah, and
That's that's the way it works. Yeah. I think they call that survivorship bias where like
You see oh you see a successful guy in you yeah, yeah, he did it that way
So let's do it that way um, but yeah
You you kind of don't see all the other factors or whatever
Almost like you if you really think about it if Steve Jobs were to be like in these tyrannical laser when if you were to?
Be less like that. Maybe there would be more
Saying, but he was so strong in these other areas that it kind of like mitigated the effects
You know there's there's businesses that are successful because they're a successful business model, and they have really bad leadership. Yeah, and even that
Kinda thing that yep. Even the bad leadership doesn't it's the the model is so good
Yeah, which is a little bit contrary because you know I would say leadership the most important thing on the battlefield
but in the business world if you have a
phenomenal idea
Then you can you can be successful on that idea alone now that is that is a unicorn that is one of those rare things?
Where you have something that's that?
Incredibly different and stands out from the crowd so much that it's gonna be successful
No matter what you know when the when the early
Gyms MMA type gyms if you had one you were successful didn't matter
What kind of leader you were because you add?
You had it and and now there's competition if you're not if you don't good leadership
And you're not putting forth a good product amongst all the competitors. You're gonna have problems. Yeah, you're gonna have problems with it
Yeah, and the more I kind of listen to you and life the more. I realize that even then the like
It's almost like you have to have a minimum
Level of leadership like you don't be have to be perfect if you have the one of these
Situations where the product of the business model no good, but still even your leadership can mess that oh, yeah
You can absolutely because you
Yeah, like you're in a situation where like now no one wants to work for you now. What oh yeah, good nice MMA
Gym, you don't have any you got to work there
Yeah
You know the whole
Time and you can't you know so it's gonna kind of fall apart after a while so maybe like it in the beginning
It'd be good, but it'll fall apart because he you sure for sure and you you can see that
Who's the guy that just got removed from uber?
I'd have to go into D. I have to really drill down on it, but the CEO of uber got removed and
You know the business models awesome. Yeah, and
They still remove the CEO. Why because there's there's issues there? Yeah, yeah, and so well
It's a great business model, but we still need good leadership. Yeah, so yeah like you like it
I'm basically confirming what you just said the good business model will get you to a certain level
But then to get to the next level and you're gonna need leadership, and that's why because it's the most important thing on the battlefield
So what the moral don't necessarily be
Tyrannical little in fact don't be straight up so radical
Yeah
Don't be and I'm not saying that there's not times where you have to have a little tyrannical flair
Because there there may be times where you need to where you need to flare up a little bit
Yeah, but it should be rare
Yeah
it should be rare the problem is it becomes a crutch for people and then they just continue to do it more and more and
more and more and then
Doesn't work
it's like it's kind of like drugs to the like when you like when you flare up on someone and
You win or whatever, you know you kind of like it works
Yeah, I worked and you kind of lay it feels good feels powerful
Mmm, so I think some people that's how you know so they'll do it and it'll work, and they'll be like yeah
I don't need that little yeah, and what's even worse is like when you win. That's where you you learn from someone
That's what you saw, and then do you do it
and you don't work for me to and I'll have to be is treat people bad and be a jerk and yell and
The my subordinates will do what I tell them to do
And they will write the subordinate will if you bark at them and scream at them
They're gonna do what you say at the moment mm-hmm the problem is what kind of team of you built. That's the problem
Yeah, what does that support? They're gonna do when you're not there. Yeah, they're gonna
Do everything they can to to cut corners and and really they don't care about they don't care about you
They don't want to do a good job for you. Yeah, so when you're not there
They're not gonna do a good job for you
Yeah, so you get addicted to yelling and screaming, but it doesn't work in the broad sense of what you're trying to make happen. Yeah
apart
Next question, I'm 26 years old. I'm currently an undercover detective. I've recently been told that I'm being promoted to sergeant
over our departments
Investigations Division
I've been the youngest person to hold a position in our departments history
All the guys I'll be in charging of our much older some in their late 40s. How do I as a younger leader lead them?
How do you demand and earn respect from an older group?
I'm ready for the job and know what the job entails
but I'm nervous to lead a group with nine people that are all older than me, so I'm
I've answered this question
Over and over again, and I'm gonna do a quick job of it here. Just because people may not
They have gone back and listened to all the other podcasts, but you have listened the answer is always the same
And it's always the same whether you're a young person leading old persons whether you're an old person leading young
people whether you're a woman leading men a men leading man leading women whether you're
Coming in from a different department
Into a new department that you don't know anybody whether you're going into a thing that you don't have experience. It's like all the same
Basically what it is you're going into a leadership position
Yeah, that's what it is be humble listen take advice build relationships keep your ego in check
Also that one of the reasons I pulled the did pull this course not easy like how do you demand respect?
Well the answer is you don't demand respect
And if you don't if you do demand respect you'll get anything but respect from people
Mm-hmm so so get that out of your head you earn respect, and how do you earn respect you respect them?
In this case you back there experience you respect their knowledge you respect it
They've been doing it for a long time you have respect for it and when you show respect for them. They're gonna respect you back
now
None of this means be passive hmm right this doesn't mean cower down
No you you still have to lead you still have to step up
But it does mean be humble be open-minded be proactive listen ask questions ask for opinions
De-centralized all aspects of operations including the planning which we already talked about and
then with all those things set a high standard and
then the final and most
Important well, I don't know it's equally important. I'd say
Work harder than everyone else and expect nothing in return mm-hmm, that's
It yeah, that's it. You're the boss you better be you better be at work before everyone and you better be
Leaving work after everyone, and that's how you develop a reputation of being a hard worker and being a hard worker in its own
right Garner's respect from most people
There's there's a fraction of losers that are like Oh echo he works so much
It's it's so lame like know why cuz I'm making them look bad or something. Yeah. Yeah, yeah
Yeah, like there's a small fraction of people that that might think that way yeah, but but no you work hard
You you put in the time you put in the effort you study?
You read what you're supposed to read you get the professional knowledge that you're supposed to get you don't impose that on people
Yeah, you have it because you're your book knowledge when you start off in this situation your book knowledge
isn't as strong as the experienced guys in this case you know in the in the law enforcement the guys that have been in the
Streets they know stuff that you don't know yeah, so you study what you can, but you keep an open mind?
so you can listen to
What their experience says yeah?
Don't impose on them
When you say don't impose it on them does that mean don't impose them like make them
It's like them echo Section four to
Alpha of the the document says that we're supposed to use this methodology when we do this yeah
You should know that methodology you should understand
Why that methodology is important, but if you say hey jogo?
We don't do it that way, and here's why I shouldn't I'm telling you by the book
It's by the book now if it's by the book because it's there's an ethical reason ok well
then that make sense but it's by the book because
That's what the book says but by the book yeah
Yeah, or you know the guy who's like who works extra hard
But he kind of in a way throws it in everyone's face. How are you?
That that's that's an important thing. It's a very important piece. Don't you don't step on people's toes with this stuff. Yeah, that's wrong
Yeah, don't do that
Check
X wish
Chuckle, I'm extremely extremely driven and have high expectations for myself and my team it appears that now I may have pushed
them too hard
and
They're developing negative attitudes. I feel like you're going to say play the game and develop relationships with them
But should I really just ignore Who I am
Should I try to be someone different than myself
Yeah, well you call that question person whoever asked this question
You called I that's exactly what I'm gonna say
I'm gonna say you need to play the game look at what your current path has done
Look at what you the real. You look what it's done real you has created a negative attitude with all your team
That's the real you
so
Is that what you want to perpetuate?
Creating negative attitudes against your deal with your team and by the way, they're just getting started
And if you think negative if you think you're gonna keep acting the same way and the negative attitudes are gonna somehow
Miraculously turn positive, that's not happening. They're gonna get more negative
Yeah, so
When people have negative attitudes I saw somebody quoted this the other day on on social medias on Twitter someone would you know?
know the quote was like no no no it's not my fault when nice my
Subordinates have a bad attitude or something like that and about a bunch of people responded you should read the book extreme
Because it absolutely is your fault it is your fault if your team has a bad attitude. It's your fault
You're the leader you own the attitude if their attitude is bad, then it's then it's actually your fault now
This is not to say that you can't have a bad apple on the team
That's completely possible and who's responsible for getting rid of the bad apples you are you're the boss
because the fact the matter is you might have a
Bad apple on your team you might even have two bad apples on your team
You don't have
14 bad apples on the team when you have 14 battles that apples on the team guess who the problem is it's you
So here's what you do a little little
Tactical advice try and get some perspective
From them trying to understand where they're coming from what challenges they face. What's pulling them off track and
When you do this, you kind of take ownership of it in your approach
so you said hey guys I I realize I don't think I'm really seeing things from your point of view and
I need to because I'm here to support you and without you performing
well
Then we fail
So I think I need to do a better job of supporting you and I can only do that if I know what your issues
Are so I can do my best to get them fixed so
What can I do better to help you alright, so now they're gonna start telling you all here's where there's this problem
There's that problem, and then what you do is you listen to their problems you actually listen to problems. You don't say
quit complaining
no, you actually listen to their problems, and then you actually see what you can do to mitigate their issues and
As you do that guess what's happening you're actually forming a bond
You're actually forming into a team because you're working together to solve issues
Again, I it sounds really simple right, but clearly here's someone asking this question now again like if you have
Some members of the team that are that are actual
negative
Complaining whiners then you might have to get rid of them
And and that's part of being a leader is knowing when you have to get rid of someone
You know I sometimes people they they take the extreme ownership attitude, and they say you know what?
I'm the leader. I own everything I'm extreme ownership
And if someone's not performing well, then that's my fault yeah, that's my fault
I need to coach a more
I need to I need to do it's my fault that my team member is not doing well and that's correct
It is your fault
It's your responsibility to train them coach a mentor um and do whatever else you can do to fix them
but at the end of the day if they still are not
competent at their task and
You've done everything you can it's you're responsible to get rid of them that is also a part of ownership
So
Yeah, like I'll have someone complaining that they've got oh this
You know one of my team leaders?
Like they're talking about their subordinate team leaders a little more like this this guy's just a bad leader mm-hmm. Why is he still here?
They owe your team that team isn't doing well because they have a bad leader whose fault is that mmm who's the leaders fault?
No, it's your fault. You're in charge of the leader. Yeah, it's ridiculous, so
Back to the original question
your
Whatever you called it. You're who you actually are is not working. Well. He probably is thinking he's a Steve Jobs
type a we got to do this, but it's not working and
He's not in a unicorn business model
That's still making a ton of money regardless, so what does he have to do play the game build the relationships?
See the perspective of your team so that you can actually
Form a team you know
Be a better leader, that's basically what I'm saying yeah
So they in it's interesting
The you know what they call framing
You know you frame something something a certain way to make it kind of sound a certain way whatever
So you say extremely driven and have high expectations for myself and my team it appears that
Now I may have pushed them too hard and they're developing
Negative attitudes so having extreme being extremely driven and having high expectations doesn't equal equal
Driving them too hard so they develop that negative. Those are two different. You know you can still be exchanged so
Yeah, you can absolutely have extremely high expectations. You can be driving extremely hard, and you can still have a
Incredibly positive attitude with our team yeah, no doubt yeah
Good point so and then it gets equated into that's just who I am
So he just kind of put it all into one ball and without one. There's no other kind of situation
It's just not how it is. No so
Apparently you might be committed
He might be committed to being all of these things and that's who I am and that's kind of it
You know kind of thing and I?
Think that's like the mistake planning people make we say this a lot. Where people will be like hey. I'm just straightforward
You know take me take it or leave it kind of thing and be like okay, but you're gonna in your case loose
You know and you're in your situation. That's the big piece
Is that in their case they're gonna lose? Yeah, so let me ask you this question if you're so driven and
You have such high expectations
That you want to win so bad
But the way you're performing as a human being and as a leader is gonna. Make you lose then
What are you supposed to do you change the way you behave you leave a better leader, yeah?
That's what you do. Yes, sir, so you take and this is total speculation on my part
But you keep kids so this equation that we're presented with
It's being extremely driven keep that high expectations keep that pushing your team hard keep that I would say to harden
That's gonna be a judgement call from day to day for sure um, but there's a part in here
That's more implied that you're being an asshole somewhere in here
You've been a so how about you take out that part?
Take out the bean the asshole part, and then keep everything else see how that goes
Yeah, cuz you kind of know when you're being a dick
I'm saying unless you're like not being honest with yourself there. Are there's some people that don't there's some feeling don't get it
There's some people who don't get it all right because it's like you know how like when you don't
Like people they just can't step outside of themselves and be like okay that to me. I wouldn't care kind of thing and like bro
Well, you know you're not me and well. I'm not you yeah, yeah, you're right. They can't attach. Yeah absolutely people that
Don't know they're socially
Incapable of
Receiving you know clues social clues. Yeah social cues from people
Yeah, you know they don't see the look in their face when they're talking to them
Yeah, that's true. I mean I'm thinking of like three
Girls yeah also that then that would go back to what you're saying how you say get input from them yes
Yes, so you gotta kind of yeah? Yeah you do, it's a solvable problem
Oh, this is a very solvable problem, and I've seen people solve this problem. I've
Helped people solve this exact problem
And the weird thing is they think and it's part ago, but it's also part. They're just I don't person they think
They're doing a great thing like they think
That they're driving when they're everything that they're doing in their mind. They're just awesome for being super pushing so hard
It's just the way. I am and all that stuff, and they think it's awesome, but again if you want to win so bad
Then you have to play the game you won't win by abusing people you won't win with a team
Anyways, it won't it won't happen
Yeah
It's no use being the best dancer if you're not invited on the dance floor
Actually that problem is so solvable that you could this is possible where you could just show just that much
Like more know caring or respect just that much respect and do for like two weeks
Yeah, just the idea that just the fact that you're doing it now people will be like hey
Where's this thing? Here's the thing if a person has an ego?
Which this person could very well have a big ego because that's why they have these high expectations
and that's why they're so driven because they just they
If they have that kind of ego, that's the person that you can't help
Because if they just look at the team and say those guys should be hard workers
Yeah, those guys aren't working as hard as me. They're not as focused as I am yeah
They don't care as much as I do so to everyone else on the team
Has a problem yeah, but but I'm perfect and you can't you know look at how driven
I am look at how focused
I am look at how high my expectations are of myself
but if you can't here's another thing if your team cannot relate to your
Expectations like they don't even they don't even see them as realistic or achievable or anything well good. What could are your expectations? Yeah?
What good are they they're not any good no good. They don't make any sense
Next wash dear Jocko I've been watching some of you youtube links with great interests
Must be a subscriber to the YouTube channel, yeah
I'm sure
You're extremely busy, but I have question
Which if you have time I would greatly appreciate your reply. I have taken thirty light opening yeah very much, so
Okay, let me incorporate that
approach
I mean I've taken up BJJ jiu-jitsu recently in London
In the UK
So uh so a beginner, I know you're a great advocate of the system
But my basic question is your opinion does it truly relate to real-life fight situations
I'm a man now approaching my mid forties in pretty good shape that I'm looking to focus on a martial
Art that would help me if I ever need to defend myself or my family
I love the discipline and humility of BJJ and as a workout
I know and I know the philosophy of BJJ is that most fights end up on the ground and
It's here that BJJ excels, but what of the other guys or what of the other guys who might be standing?
Around ready to battle bottle you or kick you in the head once you're grappling on the ground etcetera
Again, this is a question that
First of all we I've answered this a lot of times sure but I'll answer it one more time it
Jiu-jitsu is the best place to start?
You should also learn boxing wrestling kick boxing
This is all in discipline equals freedom Field Manual, so if you get that book this will be laid out for you very well
Does so so yes?
That's what you should start studying with this guy mid-40s needs wants to learn something yes start with jiu-jitsu
Does it relate to real a real life situations?
Yes, it does it absolutely does I've been in them. It's extremely effective and
You can see that over and over again speaking of YouTube you can see how effective jiu-jitsu is in real fights
now
It's important to remember that for self-defense the grappling arts in general should be used primarily to get away
It to avoid going to the ground right like when you bring up
Oh, well, what if there's other people that might be there you you should why are you on the ground?
Jiu-jitsu will give you the best opportunity to get up off the ground
That's what it gives you and then you can get away from the people that are getting ready to submit stick you with a bottle
smashed bottle or getting ready to kick you in the head if you don't know jiu-jitsu guess what you're doing you're on the ground and
You're getting kicked in the head, and you're getting stabbed with a bottle
That's why you trained you Jitsu so you can get up off the ground not so you can take someone to the ground
Because by the way
and I've said this before if
Your goal is to punch me and you're standing at a punching distance or a striking distance for me. I can just run away
That's my self-defense I can get away from you
Mmm
So that's why we train jiu-jitsu
That that's the primer. That's why you should start with it because otherwise
I'm just gonna get away from you if you're not grant if once you grab me though
I can't get away from you anymore now. I have to be able to handle myself
That's why I know you did too so I can handle myself once you've grabbed me if you're not grabbing me
I can just get away from it and run away from you mm-hmm
If you don't want to run away because it's gonna hurt your pride
Well then guess what that's that's why you train all the time
I
Mean now we go back and forth and we can talk about all the negative things that will happen if you get into a street
Fight like the fact that you can get hurt. You can get stabbed you can get shot
You can get sued you can get arrested you can ruin your life
You can do all these horrible things can happen if you get in a street fight
So so so that's why my advice to you is to avoid street fights. That's what you do and by the way
That's why you work on your awareness. That's why you make your your your your wife and your children
Aware of what's going on around them to pay attention to what's happening in the street
It's the one thing that was interesting when I was in Australia and I was in a nice part of Australia
There's an I was talking to some people about it. You know there's just a very relaxed atmosphere
Mmm where I was I was standing in a very nice part of
Australia, there's a very relaxed atmosphere
When you're
in America there's a heightened
Atmosphere there's a heightened awareness you have to have and depending on where you are and it's the same thing
I'm sure in Australia. I went to the nice part
I'm sure you could go to some some tough areas where you better be more aware of what's happening
But teach your kids because some kids don't know the difference
Maybe you don't even know the difference of what to look out for
What kind of people you need to watch out for in the street?
So work on that, and then yes train and a beer in UK and of course
I've said this before if you are truly in a situation where you feel threatened on a regular basis
well, then what you need is a firearm because
If someone's going to attack you with a knife or with a bottle or themselves having a gun the only jujitsu isn't gonna
Help you mmm boxing is gonna help you Escrima is not gonna help you if someone has a gun
So yeah, and and by the way oh, yeah, if you're in a knife fight
And you know some of scream of that will help you but what if the other guy is better than you?
What what if there's two of them?
The minute you put two people against one the odds of winning. Are it just extremely low
Extremely low does it happen. Yes it happens. Can you knock someone out? Yes, you can that's why you trained boxing?
so
Yes again
Train some jiu-jitsu start there and go and keep going and don't stop yeah
Yeah, it seems like this question always comes from a place where they just assume all these things and those things are I'm gonna
Choose to get in a fight with someone bring it to the grind in the mid the street or in your club
I don't know wherever wherever there's potential other attackers with bottles and in kicks to the head
And so all these things you just assume kind of like yeah
You take jiu-jitsu now you can go to the club and get in fights and win all the time
It's kind of like that's kind of where the question is coming from where how you said
Yeah, it allows you to get up, and it's so basic it allows you to control your situation your fight scenario. Yeah more yes
And I would even say it allows you a lot more to control it because even if even if you do take it
Let's say you take it to the circus. I meant more by a
little bit more than nothing yeah, no yeah, I'm saying a lot more because really when you think I'm in and I try to
Granted them. Yeah even like at a beginner level, so let's say okay
If you choose to engage with someone in some kind of fight right it's up to you how?
Heavy you want to take that fight you want to go to ten you go to ten you want to go to just one you
Can go to one so if you wind up on the ground which is the worst place to be if you don't know anything
On the ground yeah
And that's the site from how you say if the guy's a gun and shoots you that's a deer you're talking about that's not even
A fight scenario, that's you know?
So you wind up in the girl it's a gunfight
Yeah
If you know boxing you're gonna have almost no control over that scenario
Yeah, yeah your boxing is your boxing is not worthless
Marginalise dual sex, but it's heavily marginalized. Yeah, heavily marginalized
yeah, same thing with you know kickboxing and whatever so
There's that if you know jiu-jitsu just a little bit of jiu-jitsu if you're on the ground you have control of the fight more
Depending on your level whatever so if you if you're at that point still facing a threat of someone with a bottle or kicks to
The head or whatever while you're on the ground compare if you know you get to
Versus if you don't know did you see your still save it way more control way more so
Meanwhile like the box situation or current situation whenever it's gonna going to be less effective in controlling your situation
now if you
Don't look at it like that like if you look at it like okay, this guy's squaring up to me now
I want to mess him up as quickly as I can then okay
You know like you can do boxing and just take it to ten
But you don't have the option of taking it from one two three or nothing like yeah, but the other thing is like
It's hard to knock someone else
It's hard to knock someone I yeah does it happen yeah, it does happen and it can happen to you, too
It can happen to you, too. It's but it's hard to knock someone out and
It's it's risky as soon as you start saying okay you and I are gonna just trade punches
There's a risk from for both of us. There's a risk for me the
assurance of me being able to handle the situation the way
I want it to go by closing the distance with you getting control and getting a hold of you
If I'm trained and you're not yeah, you're you're you're done. Yeah, you're done right. That's the way it works
Yeah, and then even then that's like if you choose for this guy to be done
So if your if your sole purpose is to keep yourself safe, yeah, you could just put the guy to sleep and walk away
Yeah, or gently lambie like mount. I'm not even hurt
I'm not gonna put him to sleep nothing mount you see a guy
You can see the guy coming with a bottle or whatever way more if you know jiu-jitsu so well
There's the whole thing of when you're just used to the physical
Contact you
the the body's
Clashing and you know grappling less shock yeah?
So yeah trained jiu-jitsu
Trained boxing wrestling kickboxing, and then of course now people will be like what about judo yes trained judo
What about Zombo yes trained Sambo? Yeah?
What else what else do I need to cool? What about Krav Maga sure let's train it. Yeah, yeah train everything
Yeah, I'm down at the Starwood jiu-jitsu. Well. You said on a real general level
It's the most critical things like when someone gets ahold of you like yeah, and you put this into perspective a while ago
When you were like yeah, if someone wants to fight you walk away for runaway
Easier, but even said all these scenarios you can run away you're going you want to keep yourself safe
Yeah
You don't be there the best thing to do to avoid the the getting punched falling on the curb of dying
Getting stabbed getting kicked getting
Stabbed with a bottle getting arrested getting lawsuit getting all those things happening the best thing to do run away walk away leaf
Fully and then you said, but what happens when you can't run away because I grabbed there you have it
Yeah, so yeah, so it seems like yeah, I'm gonna train boxing so I can do self-defense. No you want to fight somebody
That's what you want to do you want to punch people in the face
It all box. No jujitsu. I mean yeah, I mean but boxing is a is a skill that every
buddy should have not everyone good people should have
Because there's two critical things on that that you learn from boxing is how to punch people on how to avoid getting punched
Yeah, and how to keep your guard up right those are important
Those are really important skills to have yeah, fully, but what what I mean is if you're starting from nothing, and you're like okay?
I'm gonna you know I'm gonna choose to address my
Self-defense you situation you have a fantasy
That you saw a guy on YouTube that was clearly a box or knock up knock out two people in a street fight
And you're like that's what I'm gonna. Do yeah yeah, that's what you actually watched was a guy
That was a Golden Gloves boxer. Yeah, who was sober?
Knockout two drunk idiots and guess what a Golden Gloves boxer will do that if you ever sparred with a Golden Gloves?
boxer they're freakin good
They're freakin good look. They're there they're there
you know like a black belt in boxing yeah, and
They will knock out two drunk guys all day long yeah
Yeah
It's weird too because the cut
If one of those if a third drunk guy or even that first drunk guy grabs a hold of the boxer yeah
And just and gets him to the ground the boxer is gonna be in trouble
You know that's the way it is we and this isn't like my thoughts this is fact
This is like I talked about some discipline in the Field Manual
It's like look. There's no conjecture. It's not like I wonder
What would happen no we know what happens?
We know what happens when two people fight, and and you can watch all the different
Various types of styles going at it
And you can watch what happens
and sure you can find the rare video where hey this boxer knocks out a couple drunk people or or
Even hey the boxer knocks out the guy does that happen yes, it can absolutely happen
That's why you train boxing do ya next question
I've not been working out regularly regularly for several years now obviously I'm fat and lazy
But I want to get after it
So the question is should I go all-in level 9?
destruction maximum madness or ease into it at level 3 cruising addition
All right well listen there's a couple different approaches you know when I hear this
First of all you you don't want to get hurt right and you also don't want to make yourself
Try and do things that are so hard and so painful that
You can't do it. Repeatedly. Yeah, so if you just destroy yourself Mac
What do you say do you destroy yourself level 9 destruction maximum madness
But then you can't work out for two more weeks. Well guess what what you do in the mean?
No, let's say realistically you got Dom's thumbs sure right delayed onset muscle soreness. Let's say you did so many
Burpees that your legs you couldn't sit down without your legs being in pain
So now don't so you take so you take three days
Four days have you ever had Dom's so bad that you took four days off?
No, okay, let's say you take three days off mmm. What did you do during those three days?
Did you hold the line did you stay on the path or were you eating?
Cheetos yeah
That's what you were doing so if you destroy yourself to where you can't stay on the path
That's not good. You want to stay on the path I
Think doing something that you can handle
Or maybe something just beyond what you can handle every single day is more important, so going at a level not not cruising level
Not level three, but let's let's find a solid level five where you can you're pushing yourself
I read a thousand words a day when I'm writing
And let you do the equivalent of that right the reason I read because if I said, okay, I'd do it tonight
I just said today. I just have to write
Five thousand words, that's five hours. Yeah, will do I have five hours today. No
I don't I can squeeze out fifty two minutes though and get thousand words written that I can do so that's
That's what I think you need to do you need to get consistent
If you bite off more than you chew then you can chew your you you might very well choke on it
So tons so don't do that
So pick something realistic
Do people say that that?
Was the first time I heard it so if you bite off more than you can chew you might choke on it
Did you make that up where you get that from somewhere? I think well
I just I don't know if I think I made it up
It's good, but I'm sure I like be like no this guy said it in 1978 yeah
There's the beauty of it, okay
So pick something realistic like something that you can handle and then get after it then the other thing here is he doesn't talk about
his diet at all and
That's clearly equally important, and you have to change
Your diet if you're gonna change your life
And you're gonna change your health so stop eating sugar stop eating processed foods. No more soda and juices and no more Gatorade
Just to start with
Or whatever it is whatever that it is that you're doing?
whoever asked this question whatever you know what you're doing if you're eating donuts and
Wrong don't don't even know that's any more stop to stop eating those get rid of that sugar, sweetness
craving thing yeah and
then just keep making your diet cleaner and cleaner as time goes by yeah, so
That's what I think is there any time that it's good because sometimes I
Think it's good when people do go like all right, man. I'm done. Yeah
Like I whatever happened they went up the staircase and they they got all tired
And they say you know what I'm done
Yeah, it starts tomorrow, but I think in those cases most the time who was it who was it that we were talking to?
Talking to someone someone that they are I was talking to someone that their first thing they try to do they couldn't do at all
Mmm like they tried to run three miles
And they were like you know what can't do it you can't run three miles
Oh it might have been that guy. There's a guy. That's losing a bunch of weight on the interwebs
Oh, yeah, that's what it is. I think he's down in, Texas
but he's trying to lose a lot of weight and
The first time he went to try to go for run
Didn't happen enough didn't happen so he had to just run less
I had to just walk actually it starts long so yeah you you start
With what you can do, but there is a little bit of?
There is there is I would try I would say this keep this one in in the back of your mind
There is the whole thing of like you know what I'm changing my life right now you go home
You get the garbage can out you bring it into the kitchen and throw away the Twinkies you throw away the?
Pop-tarts you throw away the that you pour the the crappy soda down the drain, and you get on the path
And you just don't look back. Yeah, that's a good thing to do - yeah, but again if that person's 300 pounds
They're not gonna be able to do I mean they're gonna push themselves
Yeah, they could push themselves too hard. Yeah, so you just got to be careful
Yeah, see and then it's funny when when I'm kind of looking at the question
I'm like well obviously you want to start slow right obviously, but then
You hear about these guys just like how you said they just they throw everything away
They were like I'm a different person right I think I think we're crossing streams here, or I am
There's diet, and then there's like workout
Yeah, because diet you can pretty much go cold turkey today
Yeah, it lits and you may or may not be able to relate to this
But if you cook straight extreme on your diet like all of a sudden
You're hit with these the byproducts of changing your diet especially if you'd like
like Mountain Dew every single day
And you just all of a sudden boom stop doing a bunch right you'll go through stuff that you might not expect like the craving
Li-ion free and minimal doses of mountain yeah, no yeah basically no
I'm gonna say no just stop thinking about dude. You don't need yeah, and I dig in you're gonna
Go through withdrawals right yeah through caffeine with Charles and sugar withdrawals
You're gonna get the the the keto flu and all those things are gonna happen, and it's gonna be rough, but yeah
But don't just say it like that. It's gonna be rough work. That's all bro
seriously
If you go into that and you experience these types of things and it's gonna apply to everything by the way any big change that
You make where you you have to deprive yourself of these bad things that you've become kind of addicted to or whatever
You're gonna. Go through all kinds of changes and that goes for worked out, too
By the way cuz like just the soreness alone. Oh dang. I expected the soreness
Oh, I'm like tired now because the workout like was kind of hard
It's like oh sure I wasn't expecting that I was expecting to feel great after my workout
How everyone says or whatever so you're gonna run into all these little things that no one tells you about and then it's like well
I didn't sign up for that little part of it, and then that little part
And then you're gonna have the diet thing. I think you're wrong. I think the diet thing. I think if you're good
I think it's very I think it's easier in fact to just be like I'm done
It's not like okay
You know what I'm only gonna eat a quarter bag of Cheetos a day from now on I don't think that works
I think you gotta be like no no no no Cheetos. Not no Cheetos in my house
But I do think that you could work out so hard
That you're so sore that you that you say oh, man
I'm just to like kind of like the jujitsu question earlier on like you could be what if someone's so sore that they can't do
Their job right and they're just sore all day at work. Well, that's not cool
So I think for diet you can you can go cold turkey or actually cold steak
Or hot steak sir, and then I think for working out is the one you you?
you figure out what you can do and
you push it a little bit harder, but you don't go level nine Maximum Destruction Madness I
Think you're wrong respectfully in which part do you think I'm wrong on the diet?
I think if you go extreme with your diet
I think that it'll work for some people for sure yeah, but depending on who you are
But I think your moral if you go extremely the diet. You don't like slowly phase out
You know it's interesting. I don't know if you remember
I read a letter a while back on the podcast about a guy that had read way the warrior kid and he like
Fixed his life
That guy did what you're saying. He just made little changes. Yeah. He made little changes along the way so
Maybe it's personal. It's probably personality in fact
Let's just go ahead and say it's personality because some people are gonna just have to get the damn Cheetos out of their house
All of them yeah, and some people say you know what I'm only gonna have this one cup full of Cheetos every day
Yeah, and even that's okay it, but but here's where you got to be careful you
May lie to yourself. Oh yeah, and you can lie to yourself. Yeah
I need a lie to yourself only hey, you know. I don't really that that not that big of a deal today jiff
I just have cups Cheetos. Yeah, yeah, yeah nine cups of Cheetos later
See and
Respectfully, I don't like your Cheetos example. Why because you're like
I'm gonna allow myself cheat. Okay, don't allow yourself to doze
That's not how small of a change you're gonna make if you're not gonna eat Cheetos anymore. You're not gonna eat Cheetos anymore
I'm saying like if you go extreme on your diet. Let's say you eat, but wouldn't you say what you're saying is
Hey, I'm gonna change my diet
Okay, I used to eat
every day I need a whole bag of Cheetos mhm and
Now I'm only gonna eat one cup of Cheetos from the bag a day. Yeah, that's improvement it is improvement
It's a small improvement well, and if I could do that then why why is that not okay? Yeah, okay?
if you choose to do that but
Okay, now. We're going into the specifics of a certain person's okay thing
I I would say this this is more along lines what I'm thinking as far as specific
Examples if you're gonna go if I'm gonna eat one bag of Cheetos obviously, that's not all I'm eating I'm eating other stuff
I'm the small change is I'm not gonna eat Cheetos anymore. I'm gonna cut out Cheetos. That's it
I'm still not eating that good. You know I'm kind of Cheetos or
Let's say hey, I get you. Don't drive through every day three times a day, okay? I
Won't get dressed through anymore or all that's a big change
not necessarily depending on what you get going from three Drive thrus a day to
2-0 the how is that not a big jet it's a big towers going from like
And there's certain people actually I was talking to someone the that had lost a hundred and fifty pounds female
And it was interested her nutritionist. She hired a nutritionist and the nutritionist said okay
What are the foods you can't live without yeah, and we'll work around those. Yeah, yeah, pretty cool thing
Yes, and what she said was I need cheeseburgers and fries
So then what she got told was something along the lines of okay, you can have cheeseburger and fries on
Friday yeah
Yeah, right
So the family instead of you know this this whole thing of I can never eat it now what I'm saying
Is there are people and I think I'm one of these people where it's like
Oh if I have cheeseburgers and fries today well then I might as well just get a mint chocolate chip milkshake with it
Yeah, and if I did that tonight
Then you know what tomorrow morning hey
After you get done training. Maybe if you know that cheeseburger was good yesterday
How cloud so maybe it's my own personal weakness, but for me I'd prefer to be just like on the path
Yeah, yeah
that's why the
8020 rule and I talked about this in the Field Manual the 80/20 rule
Maybe it works for some people and I guess it does work for me, but I'd rather just be straight on the program
You know what I mean, yeah
And and then and you know what you know Tim Ferriss has that thing where what he's talked about that thing where he goes
six days hardcore
Strict and then the seventh day you literally eat
Whatever you want as much as you can and I think I ride that I have and it's really really good
Yeah, because you feel really really good not
Only physically, but just about the whole day
I'm on the program
And you kind of know and on that on that cheat day you do because the cheat did you eat whatever you want?
And you don't feel any guilt at all even when you're on the 8020
It's like you have to be coming off a real strong week
To like be to feel good feels very like cheers are good, too
Yeah, and that's really that bad of a cheat day
rise
fries then you're starting to go into it for sure but the
Like you know a cheap a cheat day like a scam hilt
It'll be like for real like a whole thing of donuts Reeboks a cookie. Yeah, whatever you what straight-up, whatever
You wants is discussed?
Here's the thing though with when you when you start to eat healthy
And you then you try to eat a whole box of donuts you after like one two three, maybe six eight doughnuts
You're gonna be like
You know six. No not easy. Yeah, six doughnuts at once. Oh my gosh. You know those. I think they're called Entenmann's old-fashioned their
Little chocolate donuts, no you know what a hold on full-sized. Don't straight up. They're kind of a little bit bigger, too. You know okay?
Six don't
Ever since I started talking so much smack about Donuts. Yeah, I know I can't literally can never have one again in my life
Yeah, I know you're not allowed 400
Yeah, you never have a bite even if you were like if so knows
I can't just like that when I was a little kid my parents would buy the chocolate doughnuts the hostess chocolate yeah
That's that were all covered in chocolate and those things are good. Yeah, it can't even have one of those again
No, no, I did the six-day cheat program. No even then okay. I can't do it. You know
You know the old-fashioned donut is right. It's like a
Donut with a hole in it right. No. Oh it's called old-fashioned donut. They're like um
It's they're kind of glazed and almost like a not
They're not crispy, but they're kind of hard are hard and okay on the outside
And then they're regular soft on that something say and they have this glaze over them, okay
So I think it's I forget the name
I think it might be Entenmann's, but they have old-fashioned doughnuts where they're not as hard, but they're kind of hard, and they're just bigger
Anyway, those are my favorite ones and I used to get chocolate milk and heat up the chocolate milk
So it's like hot chocolate and donuts, and oh yeah easy money
Like I'll eat two boxes of those for sure alright you soon. Yeah. Oh, yeah
so
Now the point there is on the cheat day
You just go yeah, no shame
But after the thing is you can't just eat donuts four times a day or three
You just don't feel good like your stomach gets all upset and the more healthy you eat the more
It's gonna be like that so the longer you're on the path you start like if you ate
Some doughnut like the other day
We went to the Belmont Park, and I ate some ice cream some mint chocolate chip. Ice cream was it good
Fine it was good, but you know all the kids are doing. I never struck the other night
Yeah, you eat a big large double you know whatever after that you're like
But I don't feel right you know
So unless you're just committed to eat it cuz I don't know you don't wanna waste it or something like that
You're gonna be like all my cheat your cheat day is not gonna be that bad. That's what I'm saying
Okay, but I still don't have that. I don't make it happen it depends on what it is. Yeah
Yeah, yeah, you could pump some chili fries or something. I don't like chili fries all right, so yeah
Maybe what's the verdict?
I think just in there like middle-of-the-road nut the whole story is it balanced
Yeah, so you're saying balance as well. I'll tell you though man. If that balance doesn't work for you
You're gonna have to step it up. You have to go hardcore. I'd give yourself two weeks
Two weeks for a balanced approach on the diet side if you can't get your shit under control in two weeks
You got to go hardcore
You got to get in there with a garbage clinic can throw away the Twinkies throw away everything else
That's crap in your fridge, and yeah and go hardcore that go and start with a fast to
Know a a fast is awesome a fast wait wait
There's that much to expect the only ever a day if you never done it before it's not that big of a deal
There's no little stuff don't eat your day
There's not
Take you from a normal human being this little stuff they if you're not if you go in and not prepared for it
Then you're like oh, I don't know how actually think the more you think about it prepare for it the more psychologically
Or it is just be like oh yeah, you know what I woke up this morning. I haven't eaten last night
Calm not gonna eat until tonight
every time I think fast yeah, so
Like that when I'm like I'm not gonna eat til this then I go through little stuff
But if I just happen if I be too into work, and I'm only drinking coffee
And I forget I'm like dang if if I eat not haven't ate for like you know 12 hours
They'll be like oh, I'll just go another three
that's my fifteen cuz like 15 or eight 15 hours is when your body starts to kind of shift over to like I
Think 15 okay, whatever it's cool, so I'll just wait the extra hour. It's like cool done, but if we plan it. That's when
Yeah, I don't know but it depends on who you are man, but that's good I agree with the fans off
Yeah, a good way to kick things off and like
Jump onto the path. Yeah, just jump on with a fast. Yeah. Hey go see your doctor or whatever
Do you if you don't see a doctor too fast 24 hours? I think you should if you've been probably yeah. Oh, yeah
Fat lazy, you know especially if you're older or something like that, I think Cena doesn't he'll get a personal trainer
Depends on the helmet you know when I just talked to she's like personal trainer and nutritionist hired him both. He lost 100
whatever pounds so I
Think she was in excess of 300 pounds you know and when I met her she's completely normal right like
You know completely like you wouldn't even suspect that she had any weight trouble in her life. Yeah, that's pretty amazing. Yeah, so
hire the trainer higher the the
nutritionist yeah, I think so I think that helps I always looked at it like
Why would I hire like a trainer or something like that when I can kind of look up that stuff?
But here's the thing I went in with this bias like cuz I kind of had a background in it
So I'm like why would I can just go looking, but I'm looking it up
But I have all this other knowledge the same rule you try it for two weeks
See if you can keep yourself on the path, and if you can't got to bring someone in
Right here's what? I like hire a trainer, but not like the kind every day
It's like a once a week trainer who can get you on a little program. Yeah. Yeah, you know
It's gonna depend on you straight up. You know who can keep you on yeah, that's the mystery of all this
And I've said this a million times like you know what you need to do
Yeah, you know what you need to do
You know you know what you need to do if you can't get yourself to do it
Maybe you need to give someone to help you do it yeah
the weird thing is
Like nutritionists and stuff you can get nutritionist that could come to you and be like okay
We're gonna go put you on a low-fat diet
You know which would be really not good thing in the long term. Yeah
I don't know how many out you think there's still nutritionist that are doing that right now
Oh, yeah, there are I know there are actually they're all they're out there, so you got to be careful, right?
check
Next question
Last thing that I'm not gonna draw it out, but you said
you know what you need to do and
One time you said imagine what your day would look like like if you'd like everything you did
Was you did the things that you knew you're supposed to do kind of things well the the full the full
Statement is if you wrote down tonight
What you were supposed to do tomorrow? Yeah, and then you did the things that you were supposed to do. Yeah, yeah?
Imagine how that day would feel and imagine what you'd get done in that day, yeah
And then imagine if he did that every day for a week, yeah
And imagine if you did that every day for a month
And they did for a year and imagine where your life would be your life would be in a completely different trajectory
Completely different yeah, and that's true with working out. That's true with nutrition. That's true with business. That's true with education
That's true with knowledge. It's true with everything everything. Yeah, kind of know what we're supposed to do. Yeah well
I thought you were gonna say some people don't know what to do and that could be the case some people they've never worked out
Before and if you're a person, that's never worked out before you probably need to bring someone into the game. That's gonna help
Show you how to work out if you've never done any reading about
Eating and you have no idea what's gonna be good for you
You're probably a person that might need to bring someone into the game to help you get over that yeah
and it still completely goes with exactly what he said it's like you know what to do and
Even to help that you know what not to do like when you're about to make a decision
I'm gonna do this or not do this like you know which one is you should or shouldn't do so let's say
I don't know anything about working out
But I know I have to get in shape we all know and you know we all know when we gotta get in shape so
Then you know you're gonna hire somebody. You know you got to do something. You know that you can't just be like oh
Well, I'm not gonna do it. I don't know I'm not gonna do things to do tomorrow. You ain't a trainer. Yeah join a gym
Get a trainer. Yeah, I don't know what to do okay?
This is way you could do find out what to do there
You go in that case so you got makes sense sometimes you put things and just say stuff
Just put it on the table. Just starts to make sense
Next question, I'm a veteran of the infantry and when I took over a fire team
For the first time I made the mistake of drawing hard lines in the sand
this immediately
Alienated members of that team that had been together for some time
I did not make that mistake again, and I definitely learned from my experience
So clearly there's not a question there. Yeah, and
And I forget pulling this out
From I get a lot of emails and messages and all that but I thought it was a good point to bring up to say
You know this idea of drawing hard lines in the sand and what that does to your leadership position
It's it's a it's a difficult
it's usually not a good thing to do if you draw a lot of hard lines in the sand and
Eventually you realize that they're either
Unrealistic or people can't maintain them. You've set yourself up for failure. What is that exactly like so it's no matter what?
We will not
Go to blah blah blah. Yeah. There's the leg no matter what we will we will win
every single
Road march that we do as a fire team in this while while we're here on this training thing mmm, okay?
Well guess what that's a that's hard
There's other there's some other fire teams that are also want to win
and and so you've drawn a hard line to send that's not really a good example of a
Good example it's like no matter what we're gonna muster every morning at 4:30 in the morning mm-hmm. No matter what and
You know then the guys are out on patrol until
2:38 in the morning and now the next morning a good no matter. What level it's it's not good for them. It's unrealistic
So you drew a hard line in the sand, and now you got to back it down
So and all you have to do is soften the statement a little bit
Hey guys to the best of our ability if we can we're gonna get here every morning at 4:30 for muster
There's a little there's a little room to play there right and that's that's fine
so
again, I I there's there's
Not a lot of there's not a question here, but one of the reasons. I think that
That I that I wanted to talk about it was because I think people look at me
And even hear me on a peripheral level, and they think all I bet Chuck will just lay down the hard night
It's my way or the highway right yeah, and and
the the opposite is actually true and the reason that I
came to that conclusion
Was because I worked for leaders like that and I hated working for leaders like that
So I tried to never be a leader like that hmm
And there's a dichotomy right?
There's a huge dichotomy
Because this doesn't mean that you're not
Driving and pushing this doesn't mean that you're not saying hey. We're gonna be the best
One ever we're to be the best task unit here doesn't mean you're not saying hey look
We're not gonna rest until we've done what we're supposed to do doesn't mean that mmm
But man you gotta find that balance yeah
It does feel like that with you
Yeah, you're like it feels like that, but when you were one. I mean it my experience obviously is
We're under no like extreme
circumstances, right
But just like just like the simple stuff like it really does seem like you wake up at 4:30 in the morning every single morning
Do or die well they said I did that I do unless like there's some times where I get home at
Like I remember a little while ago
I got home at 1 o'clock or 2 o'clock in the morning mm-hm
And that's basically my cutoff zone if I'm getting less than four and a half hours of sleep
Then I'll be like oh yeah, I'll wake up and I've been like hey
I only got two and a half hours of sleep last night. That's not enough. I'm going back to bed right. That's it
That's what I mean where I've tweeted that out before yeah
higher yeah, yeah
That's what I mean. Yeah, so it's like when when that happens it almost like he catches you off guard
You know wouldn't you do when you did that I mean obviously not like oh cool daughter's trick
It's not that feeling at all. It's just kind of like oh dang
You do have that flexibility when you know when it's the correct thing kind of
Yeah, you have to yeah, you're not a slave tier uh
Rigidity well what you're saying is I don't draw hard lines in the same, yeah
Exactly right
But it's real easy to go down the slippery slope of like well. I you know I I actually
Didn't eat real good yesterday, so I probably need some more sleep to recover today. Yeah, yeah, yeah really
Yeah, well I am I'm it's a rest day. So I might as well turn on the TV
Oh, you know I'd be good with TVs. Maybe some popcorn. Oh, you know it'd be good with some popcorn
Maybe some cheese sticks in some M&Ms
It's resting right. Yeah, it went down the slippery wall back so
I guess I guess the opposite of the of the of the path is the slippery slope
Exactly right
Next question hi
Scenario that's actually a legit way to think of it, too
Yeah
If it's a legit way to think of things if you're on the path
When you know what the path is as we talked about with Tim Ferriss if you're on the path
Which you know?
Well when you step off the path, it's a slippery slope you know
It's a off the path is the slippery slippery slope and yeah
What did you just say the popcorn can lead to cheat sticks can lead to mmm? Yeah? That's the slippery slope right there?
Yeah, and sometimes you slip so hard that you just plunge deep
Off the path yeah fall off the wagon land hard
Scenario my team leaders boss came to me and asked my opinion on my horrible team leader
The boss my boss's boss
one of my opinion
So what do I do praise him to make the team look good and maintain my relationship with my with the team leader or?
Tactfully tell the truth and build a relationship with the boss with my boss's boss, yeah
That's a good question. Isn't it? I think this is a it's a really tough position to be in yeah
Because you have to be careful
And you have to be balanced and there's a couple things to think about first of all no one likes rats
Yeah, right mm-hmm
No one likes rats, but at the same time. You kind of also have to think about what's best for the team
On top of and kind of the opposite of no one likes rats is no one likes brown nosers
no, but at the same time you have to build relationships up and down the chain of command and
One of the toughest things about this and what you have to be so careful about is that you don't know what kind of relationship
The boss and the team leader have you don't know
Four on one end of the spectrum. They could be friends, so if you say something bad about him
That's going right back to the team leader, and you're in you're gonna. Have a hard time. You're in a much worse position
also, they could be enemies and
Supporting the team lead to the boss could actually
Make you look stupid right making make you look bad
And and it's important to say here
Is it
The optics of like I don't want to look bad is that what I'm talking about
Because that's what I just said like it'll make you look bad. I'll make you look stupid
the reason that you're trying to
Look good is because you want to do a good job because you want the team because you want the mission to succeed that
That's what's important, and you don't care. I don't care if I have to eat crow
I don't care if so, so I don't mind looking bad if it's for a good reason
I don't mind my ego taking a ding if it's for the right reason but
This could actually
hurt
The way I do my job mmm because now my boss my boss. Sorry my boss's boss thinks
I'm kind of an idiot and so that means when promote comes time for promotion even though I might be the best guy
I'm not getting promoted because I was the guy that was too blind to see that my team leader was an idiot. Yeah
so I would be very careful and
fairly neutral
In what I said especially to start with right, so you know if the boss says hey, how's that team leader doing?
My responsibility, you know we get the job done
There's that's so non-committal, right
Well, what about the team leader? Is he is he a good leader? I?
Think he's I think he's got a pretty good hold of what's going on, right?
So that's that's there's room to interpret that in any direction really I think he's got a pretty good hold all right
I think he's getting a hold of what's going on or
Another one would be well hey. How's your team leader? I think our performance kind of shows where we're at right
So you're not you're not giving away
and those are those are like I said those are subtle and those are very open things that you could respond to and
And I think the more your boss probes or the sorry the mo the team boss team leaders bosses probes the
More, you could open up a little bit still with caution, but as you see what the boss's opinion is you could?
open up a little bit more and share a little bit more of the truth very tactfully, or if
Or you could go in the other direction right if you just oh, you know that's my best guy
And I've known bill forever it bills. I brought him here and Bill's gonna be he's going places mmm
So you're gonna derail that guy
you you can, but you're probably derail yourself too because that guy has a legitimate relationship with
So
That's a tough
Situation and and I would say the best thing to do in this situation is remain as neutral as possible and again
You know what? There's there's someone that's listening or to this right now
That's going on jock was kind of a jock was kind of a wimp, and if I was there
I just tell the truth, okay, so let's let's talk about that
Let's talk about what happens because I've been in that situation more times than I can count
Where my boss was kind of an idiot and I get asked by his boss hey?
How's this guy doing so let's say you rat him out?
Well does that mean that the boss gets fired immediately
No, it just means that your team is less respected. It means that you get less support
It means and if you do get ratted out by the way, where do you end up now?
You end up in a bad situation where the your boss knows that you ratted him out to his boss
You're hated yeah, you're hated
I want to win. Let's go back to that point
I want to win hmm, so does it help me win if I rat out my boss
Or if I rat out my team leader to my boss does it help me win
It could
It could if your boss happens to be completely aligned with what you're thinking
He also happens to have a replacement ready. That's more squared away
That's another thing you get rid of one bad team leader now you get a new team leader. How do you know him who's that?
Who is that person? Where'd they come from the Devils? What is that saying the devil?
You know is better than the devil that you don't know
So if I have a team leader, that's not doing a good job whose fault is that?
Yeah, I can help my team leader especially if my team leader is weak
I can help them become strong I can help teach them tactfully not stepping on their toes
I would rather rather than wrap my team leader out up the chain of command I would rather fix my team leader
I would rather help my team leader become better
Support them and by the way when you do support your team leader
And they become better and now they do come up for a promotion
What do they know in the back of their mind they know that you helped them?
They knew they know that you got him there guess who's getting promoted now
You are now why am I so concerned about getting promoted. It's because I want to want to outdo everyone else
No, that's not why so you want to win because I want to win
I want the team to win, and if I thought that you eko
Would do a better job if you became team leader instead of me. I'd be like hey
I appreciate it, but echo would do a better job than me he should be the team leader so
And and also
If you're real
This is what happens if I'm really a person this this is this this is what I'm getting at if I'm really a person that
Really wants to get promoted, and that's my main goal. I want to get promoted. That's my goal
What do I do with the team leader?
I throw him under the bus so that's the person that we all hate the person that rats out the team leader that
That says oh that guy's doing a terrible job
I'd do much better job and gets that guy fired and now I get promoted
What do we all think of them we all think that guy is a turd?
Now as opposed to this someone. That says you know what our team leaders a week needs help need support
I'm gonna help them. I'm gonna support them. I'm gonna do the best I can wait
Are you saying to tell the boss this or just have that you had a bad like? I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna from one of the bus now if we have a guy
that's
Horrible that's tyrannical that does a horrible job that abuses people then we get to a situation where you say you know what boss
There are some problems. Yeah, so if you have that one which doesn't really well
this guy says horrible team leader, so if this is a horrible team leader, that's
irredeemable
Irredeemable qualities and it's negatively affecting the team cuz he kind of makes it sound like make the team look good
So there's there's there's still a possibility that the team is doing okay?
Ya know, they have a horrible leader because they are such good troops
I said I would see that sometimes a platoon has a bad leader
But there's great guys in there and the platoon leader is smart enough to be like okay
I'm gonna let them kind of run with it, and they'll be successful
Yeah
so
My goal usually is to help the person above me in the chain well
It's always to help the person above me attain a command
Can you get to a situation where someone is so bad that it's negatively affecting the whole team and you can't win because they're positioned
Yes, well then you need to step up and do something about it and say something about it. Do it tactfully do it slowly
Don't over commit to your statements early on because if you do you might say something that is out of line mm-hmm
so
That's it's a tricky situation. There's no definitive answer you have to weigh these things out. Yeah, generally
If you can help someone win you're gonna win?
generally if you help someone win you're gonna win if it's so bad that they're just
Bringing down the whole team and you cannot win with them in that position
You might need to say something. Yeah, especially if everyone on the team kind of feels the same way
It's gonna be a little bit easier to be like hey, you know yeah, and be straight
Yeah, but even if everyone if we if we have the gang mentality right like hey man the boss sucks
You know what he's team leaders horrible. He doesn't know what he's doing hey guys
You know what we just sit here complain about it, or we could actually try and like make him a better leader
Yeah, yeah well
What do you guys say think of that and then because hey we could try and get a replacement for him?
But at least he listens to us right now or whatever you know at least he's at least he understands the job hey
Let's try and let's try and prop him up
Let's try and get you know what let's get rid of him, but let's get rid of him by teaching him a lot
So he gets educated so he can move on and get promoted and then we'll have a good relationship with him, yeah
And then the team will get more support, and then we can do our mission better. Yeah
Yeah, I guess he kind of doesn't understand what makes them accountable
For sure first like what if what if I don't like him because I don't like his tie
I don't know. I don't like his hairdo. You know. I just don't like him
We don't we don't come from the same side of the tracks
I don't know what I don't think one of the things that would be like if the guys arrogant. Yeah the guys arrogant
Well, how are we gonna bring him down?
How are we gonna break? Well? How we not not bring him down?
Like bring him down from his job, but how we gonna bring down his ego. Yeah, how you gonna mellow him out
You know and that could that could be a long project hmm. That could be a long project
Yes, so just like I you said is like it is it damaging that the performance kind of thing yes
That's the most important thing is it. What is our performance like yeah, can we bring this guy around?
Good question, I'm sorry there's no definitive answer, but at the same time there's
Leadership is is an art yeah, and why did the it's an art and science, but it's an art
Sir. This is a case where the artistic part is going to be more important. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, the dichotomy all right. It's a
number one bloodsport how we called martial arts martial science
Called it martial science the guy what is named since a Tanaka right come on bro bloodsport Bend em
Yeah, no. I know I know what the movie is called. It's a familiar with that too familiar. Even as a kid
I thought those movies were really cheesy. Yeah, cheesy like so many like a lot a lot of MMA well
I guess from my age MMA gosh. You know I was in the bloodsport
You know yeah, even when I was a kid. I will I wasn't thinking blood sport was like legit
I don't know why I thought it was but we get
The dim I've got rock you I thought Rocky was more legit
Yeah, okay still yeah, I thought I thought that Rocky was more legit then blood sport for me blood sport seemed fake
Yeah
Yeah, I guess right it. Just seemed extreme. I guess cuz but plus
I think with blood sport the rumors circulated that that guy was real
Real you know so you're like. Oh sure it's a movie cool made it fun, but it was really
Yeah
Yeah, again III wouldn't say I hated bloodsport
But like I haven't seen it enough to know that the guy referred to martial arts as martial science that was early uh
early in the movie when
Van Dam's teacher you know it's your typical movie right there's a there's a guy
He's getting beat down or whatever. He goes through his training process. There's a there's a montage
Like in the team or Team America world police
There's a montage training montage, and then he comes back and went that there's there's like most of your fight movies
Yeah, you know the montage yeah, he gets beat done early
You know he trains he becomes awesome, but then there's the arch enemy who's trained to yeah
But still a bully and he has to beat him same thing with credit kid
But you're leaving out the montage part a training montage. Yeah, which is very important
You're the best. No that's credit. Kid. Yeah, you ever seen the movie never back down
No, okay, so you wouldn't you'll never watch this movie. It's it's
It's MMA right. It's I remember when it came out. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, but it's basically Karate Kid
it's it's literally like Karate Kid, but just MMA now and a
Little bit more cheesy, maybe a lot more cheesy. I thought it was good though
I enjoyed it and watch them watch me learn from like a master jujitsu guy or something yeah
Brazilian guy who plays is played by an African guy the guy on your remember gladiator
You know gladiator right Russell Crowe any of the black guy in there the African guy vaguely yeah?
He um you know the one yeah the main friend. He's the guy but he's a Brazilian guy, okay
It doesn't match cuz I don't know Brazilian X. I was gonna say houses on Portuguese accent. No haha I still African, but nonetheless
You know on paper it might seem cool, but it came out kind of cheesy. No. I liked it though you know they
Overemphasize like all the things like he goes to the party and the party is just me way
Yeah, look into it nonetheless. Yes science and art. I dig it. You kind of have to buy me back the question
Yeah, I have to kind of wonder why the boss is asking your opinion - is it just a general probe like hey
How you guys doing? How's the boss doing kind of like that or is it? We have some concerns about your team leader?
What up, you know kind of thing yeah, and even that you got to be careful. Yeah, because they could lead you down that path
Maybe maybe they're probing you yeah, yeah, maybe the leader said hey you know what I don't trust this guy he says about me
Right, and then you go in and you go hey. I've heard some bad things about this guy. What do you think of them?
Yeah, I'll tell you what you're right that guy's our dude. Yeah turd with years
Yeah a lot of teammates they turned the team thing I think I think it came from buds at some point yes
It was you'd get called turds
quite a bit, and then a person that was kind of
Maybe just just not a very good individual would be a turn in years
Anyway they say you do boy same thing do do boy do - boy yeah, but obviously not in any kind of
Discipline said we're here one more one more question
Yes next question last question chuckle. I've been disciplined working hard and staying focused
but I've hit a
Run of bad luck, and I can't seem to get a break
Well
First of all you are lucky
Because if you're capable of of working hard, then that's a blessing that's luck
Because there's people all over the world
That don't have the ability for any number of reasons
Many of those reasons being just bad luck that they can't work so right out of the gate. You're lucky that
You can get up tomorrow, and you can go to work now you say you can't get a break
And
Maybe you're getting unlucky with your career or your personal life, or your business
So
What are you gonna do?
Are you gonna give up
Are you gonna
Surrender are you gonna assume that because you didn't catch a break today?
There's no way you'll catch one tomorrow or next week or next year
Are you going to
Leave in all the chance
Or. Are you going to do everything in your power to force lock your way to create?
Opportunity to to shift the hands of fate
And even then if
the break never comes even if you roll across the finish line of life bruised and bloodied and
empty-handed
From the fight at least you know
You know
That you went after it as hard as you could
Then you gave life everything you had
And you know in the end
You might still be unlucky
That could happen, but I would much rather be an
unlucky soul
That fought until the end and died with my sword in my hand
Then an unlucky soul
That's submitted
Bow down gave up and surrendered
So stop waiting to get lucky stop waiting for a big break instead
Be thankful
Truly thankful
For what you do have and
Go out there and fight and battle and brawl to make your own luck
And I think that's
All I've got for tonight
So echo just speaking of fighting hard
Sure is there anything?
You know about that can help us
Stay in the fight stay in the fight continue fighting art check sure first thing you do need to do is take care of your
body habitus
Use that word wrong but body habitus is like your move like your habitat on your body
Anyway, take care of your body is what I meant
Including but not limited to your joints a
Lot more important than I thought from the beginning or at in the beginning
So how you do that is super krill oil Jocko has super krill oil?
chocolates krill oil called super krill oil
Another supplement called joint warfare. These are good for your joints. Don't neglect them. That's how you see in the fight straight out
Get them at origin main comm also you want to
Increase your capacity and capability in the fight
physically mentally
You take new product called discipline. It's called discipline
It's not discipline itself it's called discipline anyways cognitive and physical enhancer force multiplier
Mental plus physical the the sum is greater than the parts
Anyway origen main calm that's where you get them really good. They also have use in rash guards. They're at origin me and
They are all made in America. I don't know if you know this it's a big deal
He does good work over there from the dirt to the shirt. Yeah
Cotton is even grown in America, and that's very important see what I did there
Jockeys rash guards compression gear pants
compression pants spats
All they're also or just speaking of origin. We have an immersion camp jiu-jitsu immersion camp all
Levels of jiu-jitsu are welcome to this by the way, what about kids kids welcome to that one
I don't think so the AK is something they have the capacity for kids there. Yeah shoot. They're asking me that
Interesting nonetheless all levels even if you don't have any jiu-jitsu at all in fact last time
There was a group who didn't have I think it was like some didn't have any dude no, dude it
Just came to win unless like you know like some of the stuff you learn if you don't have any juice it's like okay
That's not gonna fit into my knowledge because you have no knowledge so it's like that's not I don't understand this quite yet you get
It like no we did. They're like the fundamentals class for him
Yeah, yeah, yeah, and even during um like while he was going on
I I had a group on the site of like a good like 12 people
And we're just doing just the basic no
No, yes, yeah for sure all levels and by the way if you're a beginner yeah, that's cool, but also if you're good
You'll also get some awesome training there. Yeah, everybody great guys there, yeah
Huge good. It's cool. Yeah. It's all butts up in Maine
Echo Lake, I really like this everyone oh, yeah, we yeah, crank. Yeah, yeah Echo Lake
Echo's got his own Lake
Sure Echo Park Echo Lake dang
Nonetheless. Yeah, so yeah origin mancom you can look and see all that stuff
And you know if you want something get something if you want to come to the emergency camp
Come to the immersion camp. I'll be there chuckling yeah
You so mad last time you couldn't do that your rib. Yeah, read Braille rib was Jackson
This year won't be jackets no no no
Either way also for fitness gear when a very of your workout you want to implement new
movements
kettlebells
D-do kettlebells, I know JA. Can you do kettlebells I know that but that's the question yeah
You do Mike grand chief right Mike this guy. You know he's a brown belt or black belt
I forget I'm in
Carlsbad area
You know I've known him for a long time. I used to work with his sister
I don't even know if he remembers that but so watching you know you know Jeff Clark. Yes. Yeah, yes
He hit me up. He was like hey. I want to get into kettlebells now
He's like I'm looking at the on it ones or whatever. You know asking the advice
Here's the thing I'm not an expert on the kettlebells, but I do know this don't get nuts with them
But don't go too late either though. I bought a kettlebell for my daughter. She's five now, so it's just it looks cool
It's like one of the little hundred four kilograms
The smallest one yeah, but when I pick that up, I'm like no matter what fitness level
I'm at this isn't gonna do much for me, so don't go too late is what I'm saying. Yeah
Yeah
Nonetheless get them from on it go on it. Calm slash chuckles some good stuff a lot of options there
You think you're stuck in a boring Jocko workout super hard, but but boring you're gonna fall off that way again
Maybe I don't know depends on me your butt if you want to vary it up go on it
Doc on slash chuckle get some do some good finish good
also
When you're getting any of the books that we review on this podcast I got am organized for you on
jockle podcast comm click on the top books book section I
Think specifically it says books from chaco podcasts got them organized by episode including Rob Jones journeys
Journal by the way pretty much anything that we're reading
I'm gonna put it on there for access easy access and it happens to support takes you to Amazon boom get your book
two-day delivery one-day delivery eight-hour delivery sometimes
And you know it's gonna do other shopping continue on do you be you?
Also subscribe to the podcast if you haven't already iTunes stitcher Google Play a Spotify
Stitcher I already said to do it
Everywhere yeah everyone whatever you listen to podcasts on subscribe
Yeah
Seems obvious right also YouTube if you are interested in the video version of this podcast go and see what chocolate looks like
if you care
You'll see what I look like if you care
Which may be a little bit more of a thing because I don't sound how I look still get that by the way
Yeah, no. I just talked to a guy about the other day. Yeah, yes yesterday
That'll never go away huh nope
until everyone has seen me
No one sees me anyway if you are interested in that youtube video version of this podcast also excerpts
Take little chunks out of the podcasts and post them so you can share them
So they don't have to listen to two and a half three hours of a whole podcast again one lesson one specific lesson
That's not a YouTube channel, and you just made a new video
I did yeah, I'm making more videos now time is running out time is running out
It's no video short doing you know the you know so I'll choose little
Excerpts or whatever it to be like you know what this one to me
Hit harder this little message
That you said and that
One was cuz it is one of those ones cuz you know how they the old saying where it's like
Yeah, we know we had to have a limited time on this earth, but we don't act like it
Yeah, you know that whole thing and really when you think about that
that's more true than I think most people realize and
You know that's why people go through like midlife crisis right you know they they hit a certain age
I'm gonna get my ears pierced and get a Corvette. Yeah, I
Don't know you know it's that scrambling situation. You know you trying to scramble to get get more in
But you know there's gonna come a time you can't do that there a little old-school footage in there in that video. Yeah - oh
if you want to see me when I was I
Don't like 13 or 14 sure maybe yeah, I was probably 14
I'm gonna guess 14 Bronson's children Bronson's children. What's that Bronson snatchin nonsense? That was straight up it
Is right yeah, okay?
- identify fully the actual because we had a bunch of different names
one of the names of the band was rage of discipline
The range of discipline, but it was never disciples of discipline no
This one it was rage of discipline. You know and
It was it was struggle
It was Lock and Load
Which is really militaristic for someone that wasn't in the military to be like my bands called lock and load
I realize how cheesy that is now. That's really dope back well
I don't know, but anyways rage of disciplines real military ish seem bright you were you even before yeah
That's what the guy. You got the video footage from Elgin James. He what he comes on the podcast? He's okay?
I'm gonna tell people he I actually just
spoiler alert exact
I can't wait to tell everyone that you had a band called rage of discipline when you were 14 years old no, yeah
And I was kind of laughing about that yeah
Yeah, but yeah, you're in the making from the beginning. Yeah, yeah, I guess you could say that but you know also
I I also look back and think well man. I did some dumb stuff when I was a kid. Yeah well
You didn't get a handle on the discipline till later, but you know the seed was there
You know like a little rattlesnake
You know how they say they're the most dangerous because they can't control the venom they don't have the discipline
Oh, but they want the discipline. That's what I think that's what I was like a little rattlesnake. Yes
Right nonetheless you can see these videos on you. Well the video is a cool video. Yeah. Thanks. Joe. Good job echo Charles. Thanks
Should I do more videos?
Also, Chuck was a store called jaco store. This is where you can get
Discipline equals freedom shirts. There's that word again discipline
you know
iconic one also
rash guards on their
women's stuff on their hoodies on their
Beanies here's the thing be nice out a little bit more of a process
But I mean approved and you know there's gonna be some beanies on their new shirt is out. Just in time for summer
Good job
Even there they'll need him down in
Australian New Zealand yeah, it was summertime down there. Yeah in the southern hemisphere yeah in Hawaii
You're wearing a new shirt today. That's right is this out back to the book. It's out its out
It's available because I didn't say anything
I just kind of snuck it on there so some people got it so it's live its life or in life
Or add a video book back to the book
It's actually good the front of it has a book on the back has all the titles that you've reviewed or
You know gonna see what that looks like Jaco store calm if you want something get something. It's a good way to support
Also psychological warfare if you know what that is it's an album with tracks that each track is
Engineered it's not music tracks chocolate tracks
Engineered to help you through any moment of weakness that you may stumble upon or that might stumble upon you
Ike you shouldn't say stumble upon you because that kind of gives the ownership to like oh it happens to me yet I mean
If you hit weakness you hit the weakness like you
You stumbled on the weakness you can't blame the weakness you blame you see I'm saying sure so any
Moment weakness that you happen to stumble upon
There's a track for that procrastination
Waking up early the diet stuff falling off the diet wagon you want to eat some donuts because they're free at work
It's wasteful. If you don't eat them. It's disrespectful to the person who bottom
And your your you're gonna eat them. That's weak stay on the path, and if you need a little spot
Psychological warfare you can get it on iTunes
Amazon music various where we can purchase
Mp3s both get it from their psychological or her
It's a good one. Good way to support to by the way a way to support also
If you need some more support you can get Jacque a white tea
And I've got some bad news and good news
Bad news they've started testing for jock a white team
So they started testing they're worried, you know they see guys just
Dominating and they're thinking they're probably on jakka white tee the good thing
That's the bad news good news is doesn't matter can't test for it all-natural
It's all natural no one can believe that a fully natural substance can
Can raise any human beings deadlift to eight thousand pound minimum, but there it is it is factual
factual
Books
All right books you can get some books weigh the warrior kid
This is the book for kids
The book for kids see the feedback go on
Go on social media go on Twitter
Go on Facebook you Bo. Ha and see kids
Studying see kids doing pull-ups see kids doing jiu-jitsu see kids getting after it that'll tell you right there
So many parents have said I can't believe my kid now wants to study as they post little pictures of kids making math
Flashcards that's what I'm talking about imagine if you get your kid to do math flashcards voluntarily
Boom, so that's what I'm talking about and now there's a way the warrior kid to Mark's mission in this book
Uncle Jake
Teaches young mark and he really teaches the rest of us how to control his temper
how to work hard how to be frugal and smart with money there's a little
entrepreneurial activity in the book
He also learns how to take care of his gear. He learns how to save his money. He learns how to deal with
Insults and with verbal abuse, and he learns to overcome his fear of failure
That's a lot to learn in one book
Yeah, but it's there the lessons are there and it's done in a simple clear way that only uncle Jake knows how to do
And speed of entrepreneurial or your kids don't forget about Aiden
Young Aiden. He's only 12 years old, but he has a business
He's making soap from goat milk from goats on his farm
And he's not just making any soap. He's making good soap. He's making Jacko's soap mmm
You can order it at Irish red Irish Oaks ranch calm and the motto which I thought have not given Aiden any credit for this
He didn't think of this motto. I thought of the motto
The motto is stay clean
so ya get yourself some chocolate so
You can also get a book called the discipline equals freedom Field Manual, and that's another book the feedback is awesome
The feedback is awesome
people that get that book and
They get on the path they get stronger healthier smarter more disciplined
they're get better and they live a better life, and that's awesome to hear so if
You or someone. You know needs to know how to get on the path and stay on the Baths path
Then the field manual is for them, and it'll help them do just that and for the audio version
It's not inaudible
Because then you can't have an album with tracks the audio version is on iTunes Amazon music google play other mp3
platforms so if you want the audio version get that
also
obviously
There's a book called extreme ownership it is
Combat leadership these are the lessons that we learned in combat translated into leadership principles for business and life
And you know what still on the on the sound charts right now is number 17 on all Amazon charts for
Books red or something like that so yeah
You got to dig that it's still selling and and and also
announcement
Just went over a million copies sold
Yeah, which is pretty legit? So thanks everyone for doing that for?
Buying some books some copies of books and by the way
You don't sell a million copies of a books of a book on just hype
And and we didn't do it through paid advertising
Which I don't even know if you could do it through paid advertising the book sells because the word of mouth
so everyone that listens this podcast buys the book spreads the word gets it for other people your
Reason that that book is selling so well still
So thank you all for
spreading the word
Telling people get it for them get it for their team up and down the chain of command extreme ownership. Pick it up
Furthermore national on front that's my leadership and management consulting company
We solve problems through leadership. That's what we do and that is how all?
Problems get solved through leadership
So it's me. It's lave babban. It's JP. Danelle. It's Dave Burke
you can email info and echelon front com or you can go to the website s LAN front comm and
Of course we are approaching the muster
This is the most dynamic
Leadership conference ever
of all time
Tickets are selling
We've already kind of
Expanded the floor in the location that we have in DC as much as we can to accommodate more people
But I'm telling you it's gonna sell out
We're only doing two musters this year one is in Washington DC May 17th and 18th
And one is in San Francisco October 17th and 18th so come learn hang out get your
pragmatic leadership skills
and
Also, it's important to know that there's no green room. There's no backstage will be there hanging out answering questions talking eating
working out and
Hanging out with everyone that shows up so join us there
You can register at extreme ownership calm and also on extreme ownership. Calm. There's a document that we put together
so some people they want to come to the conference they need to run it up their chain of command and
They kind of say what should I say up my chain of command
I want my chain of command to pay for which is awesome and the chain of command should pay for it because they're gonna get
Back a much better leader in their organization, but we put a document on there you can you can
click on the link that the little
What's that that little link I guess it's called the Lincolnshire called creating leaders at every level, and that's also on extreme ownership calm
We'll see you there. We'll see you at the muster and
Until we do see you at the mustard you can find us
interacting and conversing and cruising
on the interwebs on Twitter on Instagram and on that
double hockey Becca
Is that echo Charles and I am at jockey willing and thanks?
To those of you out there and uniformed around the world on foreign lands
In the sky over our heads and on and under the high seas
Protecting us from the evil of the world. Thank you, and thanks to police and law enforcement
To the firefighters and paramedics and all of you first responders. Thanks for taking care of us and our families
When we need it most and to everyone else out there
the nurses and the doctors
working all hours to heal us and the teachers trying to educate our youth and the guys hanging drywall and
Pouring concrete and roughing in plumbing and electrical and the farmers growing crops and the factory workers
building products and the fishermen and the lobstermen and the
longshoremen and the bankers and the advisors and the salespeople and the waitresses and the cooks and the
dishwashers
To all the men and women across the land and every job in every capacity that show up everyday
Thanks for listening to us, and thanks for doing your job and doing it well and doing it with pride
And thanks for working hard to make your own
Luck and to make your part of the world a better place
By going out there and getting after it
And so until next time this is echo and Jocko out